this morning we have an update on the
story of a ceo who made a stunning
announcement on employee pay this was
more than six years ago when we first
told you about it 2015 dan prices his
name he raised the salary of everyone at
his seattle credit card processing
company to at least 70 thousand dollars
a year at least
price's decision was met with
predictions of bankruptcy from his worst
critics but we're here to tell you now
that has not happened
instead the company is actually thriving
and as carter evans shows us the higher
pay has helped employees buy homes and
start families
new parents and co-workers carrie chen
and alex franklin can't wait to
introduce their son to colleagues at
work a company they say made it possible
for them to begin a family in the first
place and you weren't the only ones that
had a baby huh no everybody had a baby
so it's a baby boom here why do you
think that's happening
we can afford it they both work at
gravity payments in seattle a credit
card processing company with a ceo who
six years ago did something that shocked
everyone and we're going to have a
minimum
70 000 pay rate for everyone that works
here
you had people making 35 000 a year but
you told them you were going to double
their salary yeah and then you actually
had to do it right how did you pull it
off well it's tricky you know i took the
million dollar pay cut that's right a
million dollar pay cut
dan price was simultaneously hailed as a
hero and eviscerated as an enemy of
capitalism lunatic of all lunatics dan
price personally i think he's a
socialist i hope this company is a case
study in mba programs because it's going
to fail but that didn't happen
so you've almost doubled the number of
employees and you've tripled business
yeah and you're still paying a minimum
of seventy thousand dollars a year
correct how much do you make
uh i make seventy thousand dollars a
year to pay his own bills price
downsized his own life sold the second
home he owned and tapped into his own
savings i think it was a big risk andrew
haffenbracht teaches at the university
of washington's foster school of
business it does go against what
people expect and what we usually see in
terms of corporations and companies
these days average ceo compensation is
320 times more than the salaries of
their typical workers
this shows that isn't the only way for a
company to be successful and profitable
do you pay what you can get away with or
do you pay what you think is
ideal or reasonable or fair why aren't
more companies doing this
i would say that's the failure of this
you know i feel like i've been shouting
from the rooftop like this works this
works everybody should do it and zero
big companies are following suit because
the system values
having the highest return with the
lowest risk and the lowest amount of
work
but price thinks gravity's returns are
up in large part because bigger
paychecks have led to fiercely loyal
employees our turnover rate was cut in
half
so when you have employees staying twice
as long their knowledge of how to help
our customers skyrocketed over time and
that's really what paid for the raise
more so than my pay cuts meeting them
where they are the company did take a
hit during the pandemic losing 55
percent of its business in march 2020 at
one point price figured gravity was only
four months away from failing but it
bounced back after its employees
voluntarily took a temporary pay cut we
reduced our salary to forty thousand
dollars yeah i think we took
each about somewhere around sixty
percent are you back up to normal now
not only back to normal gravity repaid
us all of the pay cut that we had
voluntarily given up are we going to get
a little uh play pen in here for you
price says baby thomas is one of 60 new
additions to the company family over the
past six years he also claims the number
of employees buying homes has gone up
tenfold we are right on track for the
american dream you know we have a
beautiful baby boy a wonderful home a
beautiful life we're not only
just living we're able to thrive and
they're able to say thank you to the man
who made it possible he has his dream
car we're like hey let's like if we all
chip in just a little bit we can make it
happen and we did
oh my god
my employees have done way more for me
than i could ever do for them so the
fact that they wanted to get me such a
such an unreal amazing gift it's it's
pretty special i don't know if i can put
it into words you could have afforded
that with your old salary
yeah that's true i'm way happier now
than i was before oh this feels good at
gravity payments it seems like there's a
lot of that going around
for cbs mornings i'm carter evans in
seattle
it was a beautiful story on so many
levels gorgeous first dan does that then
the employees do that and then they get
dan and tussle he's always wanted
all of it thank you carter well done dan
well done dan